the Earth provides we cultivate and
nurture this is the essence of farming
it's a partnership as old as Humanity
itself two of the most vital plants in
this partnership are rice and vegetables
they sustain billions around the world
understanding their cultivation is
crucial it ensures food security and
nourishes our bodies and the planet this
guide is a journey we will explore the
intricacies of rice planting and
vegetable harvesting from the
preparation of the soil to the moment of
harvest
we will uncover the secrets of
sustainable practices join me as we
delve into the world of farming let's
ReDiscover our connection to the land
and the food it provides these are more
than just farming techniques they are a
testament to human Ingenuity they
represent our deep connection with
nature rice a staple food for a
significant portion of the world begins
its life as a humble seed this tiny
grain holds the potential to n nourish
families and communities its Journey
from seed to our tables is a testament
to the intricate dance between humans
and nature we start with the seed itself
carefully selected for its resilience
and suitability to the local climate and
soil the seed is then planted Often by
hand in a carefully prepared Patty the
Patty a flooded field provides the
perfect environment for the rice to
germinate and grow weeks turn into
months as the rice plants mature their
emerald green leaves swaying in the
breeze the Patty a vibrant ecosystem
teeming with life becomes a testament to
the interconnectedness of nature Farmers
meticulously manage the water levels
ensuring the rice has the perfect
balance of moisture and
oxygen before a single grain of rice is
planted the land itself demands
attention the creation of a rice Patty a
flooded field specifically designed for
Rice cultivation is a meticulous process
it requires a deep understanding of the
land and the plant's needs the first
step involves plowing or tilling the
soil this breaks up compacted Earth
creating space for air and water to
penetrate organic matter such as compost
or manure is often Incorporated to
enrich the soil and provide essential
nutrients for the rice plants this
organic matter acts as food for
beneficial microorganisms in the soil
further enhancing its fertility leveling
the field is crucial for ensuring even
water distribution this is often done
manually using simple tools a testament
to the labor intensive nature of
traditional rice farming proper leveling
prevents water from pooling in certain
areas which could suffocate the rice
plants or create an uneven growing
environment with the Patty prepared the
cycle of Life Begins rice seedlings
carefully nurtured in a separate Nursery
bed are gently transplanted into the
flooded field the water a defining
characteristic of rice cultivation plays
a multifaceted role in the plant's
growth acting as a natural temperature
regulator the water Keeps The Roots at
an optimal temperature for growth it
also helps to suppress weeds giving the
rice plants a competitive Advantage the
depth of the water is carefully
controlled throughout the growing season
as the weeks progress the rice plants
transform from delicate seedlings into
robust stalks their Roots anchor firmly
in the Muddy Bottom of the Patty drawing
up nutrients and water the air above the
water is alive with the hum of insects a
symphony of Life sustained by this
unique ecosystem
section five Nature's challenges pests
and the importance of climate the life
of a rice farmer is not without its
challenges pests and diseases a constant
threat to any crop require Vigilant
monitoring and careful management
climate 2 plays a crucial role in the
success or failure of a rice Harvest
insects drawn to the abundance of the
Patty can decimate a rice crop if left
unchecked traditional methods of pest
control often involve introducing
natural Predators such as ducks or fish
into the Patty to keep insect
populations in check climate change with
its unpredictable weather patterns poses
a significant threat to rice production
droughts can lead to water shortages
stressing the rice plants and reducing
yields conversely excessive rainfall can
flood the patties drowning the plants or
making them susceptible to fungal
diseases sustainable farming practices
which we will explore in the next
section offer solutions to mitigate
these challenges
section six sustainable rice farming a
partnership with nature sustainable rice
farming is not just a technique it's a
philosophy it recognizes the
interconnectedness of the environment
the farmer and the consumer this
approach prioritizes practices that
minimize environmental impact while
maximizing yields and ensuring the
long-term health of the land one key
principle is reducing water usage
traditional rice farming often involves
continuous flooding which can lead to
Water waste and methane emissions
sustainable methods such as the system
of rice intensification or SRI promote
intermittent flooding allowing the soil
to aate and reducing water consumption
organic farming practices which is shoe
synthetic pesticides and fertilizers are
also Central to sustainable rice
production instead of relying on
chemicals organic farmers utilize
natural methods such as crop rotation
and compost application to build soil
fertility and control pests
section seven from field to table the
art of harvesting vegetables as we
transition from the watery world of the
rice Patty we enter the diverse realm of
vegetable harvesting unlike rice with
its single Harvest Time vegetables offer
a continuous Bounty throughout the
growing season knowing when and how to
harvest each type of vegetable is
crucial for ensuring optimal flavor and
nutritional value root vegetables such
as carrots and potatoes are ready for
Harvest when their foliage begins to
yellow and die back leafy greens on the
other hand are best picked when they are
young and tender timing is key
harvesting too early can result in
underdeveloped flavors while waiting too
long can lead to tough bitter vegetables
the methods used for harvesting
vegetables vary depending on the type of
plant and the scale of production small
scale Farmers often rely on hand
harvesting a labor intensive but
rewarding process that allows for
careful selection of the best produce
larger operations May employ mechanized
Harvesters to efficiently gather crops
like potatoes or
tomatoes Section 8 tools of the trade
harvesting with care and efficiency just
as a carpenter relies on a well stock
toolbox so too does a vegetable farmer
depend on a range of tools to
efficiently and effectively Harvest
their crops these tools often simple in
design but essential in function are
extensions of the farmers's hands
allowing them to gather the fruits of
their labor with care and precision for
Harvest in leafy greens and herbs a
sharp pair of scissors or a harvesting
knife is indispensable these tools allow
for Clean Cuts minimizing damage to the
plant and ensuring that it can continue
to produce for root vegetables a sturdy
Garden fork or a broad Fork is used to
loosen the soil around the roots making
it easier to pull them up without
breaking larger vegetables such as
watermelons or pumpkins may require the
use of a harvesting knife or a pair of
pruning shears to separate them from the
Vine regardless of the tool used the
goal Remains the Same to harvest the
vegetables at their peak of freshness
while minimizing damage to the plant and
the surrounding
environment section nine preserving the
Harvest techniques for quality and
Longevity the joy of harvesting fresh
vegetables is often followed by the
Practical concern of preservation how do
we maintain the quality and extend the
shelf life of our hard-earned produce
fortunately humans have developed a
range of techniques over millennium to
preserve the Bounty of the Harvest
ensuring access to nutritious food
throughout the year one of the oldest
and most effective methods is drying by
removing the moisture from fruits
vegetables and herbs drying inhibits the
growth of bacteria and mold extending
their shelf life significantly suying a
simple yet effective method involves
spreading the produce out in a single
layer in a well ventilated area exposed
to direct sunlight for preserving larger
quantities of produce dehydration using
an electric food dehydrator offers a
more controlled environment other
preservation methods include pickling
fermenting and canning pickling which
involves submerging vegetables in a
brine solution preserves their Crunch
and adds a Tangy
[Music]
flavor section 10 a shared Harvest tips
for Farmers of all levels whether you're
a seasoned farmer with acres of land or
a city dweller tending to a small
balcony Garden the Journey of
cultivating food is filled with
continuous learning and shared with
wisdom here are a few tips gleaned from
generations of farmers to help you along
your own agricultural Pursuits for
beginners starting small is key choose a
few easy to grow vegetables such as
lettuce radishes or beans to gain
confidence and experience don't be
afraid to experiment with different
varieties and techniques to find what
works best in your specific growing
environment experienced farmers can
benefit from embracing Innovation
explore new crop varieties experiment
with companion planting and stay
informed about the latest developments
in sustainable agriculture regardless of
your experience level connecting with
other farmers in your community can
provide invaluable support and knowledge
sharing section 11 feeding the world the
importance of sustainable agriculture as
we conclude our exploration of rice
planting and vegetable harvesting it's
crucial to recognize the profound
significance of these practices in the
context of Global Food security with a
growing global population and the
increasing threats posed by climate
change sustainable agriculture is not
merely a choice but a necessity
sustainable farming methods by
prioritizing soil Health water
conservation and biodiversity offer a
pathway to produce more food with fewer
resources while minimizing negative
impacts on the environment by embracing
these practices we can ensure that
future Generations have access to the
nutritious food they need to thrive the
journey from seed to table is a
testament to human Ingenuity and our
interconnectedness with nature by
supporting sustainable Farmers
advocating for policies that promote
ecological Agriculture and making
conscious food choices we can all play a
role in creating a more just and
sustainable food system for all